The United States of America
is a relatively new nation,
haven't been founded only a few hundred
years ago. However, despite its youth,
it has quickly risen to become a world
power and has had and currently has a
major impact on economics, politics,
technology and science, the arts,
culture, and other aspects of
society across the entire globe.
What began as English settlements on
the coast of a world unknown to the
settlers would come to conquer that world
and rise to claim the title of world's
superpower.
In the meantime,
the nation would change considerably
as it expanded and forge an identity,
and in this video we're going to
discuss that identity and the history.
So let's get to it.
The land we call the United States today
had been inhabited by various native
American peoples as long
before its existence.
These people were to send it from a
group of Eurasians across the Bering Land
Bridge about 16,000 years ago.
Many of them develop some
considerably complex societies,
which would cross paths with the Europeans
and their expansion into the region.
However, the United States is
politically, economically, socially,
and culturally much more to send it from
European, the native American elements,
Americans and native Americans consider
their histories separate up until the
intertwining of the two and the histories
of the various indigenous peoples
before the USA will be covered in depth.
In future videos,
Americans typically begin their country's
story with the voyages of Christopher
Columbus. We now know that at least
one other old world civilization,
the Vikings reached America before
Columbus and possibly others,
possibly even other Europeans,
but even though Columbus was not first,
it was his journey that
began the processes that will
lead to the linking of the
old and new worlds and thereby the
United States. So he remains irrelevant.
Figure Columbus sailed to the new world,
essentially to find a new trade route
to India as the traditional route to the
east have been cut off by the
hostile and Muslim Ottoman Turks.
When they captured Constantinople,
he landed in the modern day Caribbean
and claim the land for Spain.
Those Spain and Portugal will later to
spit the land claims and settle it with a
treaty of tourists.
Hideous Columbus would never realize
that the land in which she had landed was
not Asia and the fact that he was unaware
that he had landed in an entirely new
continent is why the native Americans
are a times still referred to as Indians.
It was only realized shortly after his
death by America vis fugi after whom the
continent is actually named his Latin
name being America's Columbus will be made
governor of the area,
but as brutal rule over the native peoples
would have hoard the Spanish monarchs
and caused him to remove him from power.
Columbus died in 1504 but
its effect on history,
the linking of the two worlds for better
and for worse with long outlive him.
The Europeans were now very
greatly interested in the
land resources and all the
opportunities that this new world
had to offer. Spain and Portugal,
what continue to lead the charge into the
Americas for at least the next century
and extend the grip across much of
north central and South America.
Immediately after Spain's discovery,
the other late 15th century major
powers of Europe, Portugal, France,
and England realized they needed to
jump into the theater right away,
a wave of explorers be sent to
the new world and coming decades.
The King of England,
Henry that's seventh,
was introduced the concept of finding a
northern route to China by an Italian by
the name of Giovanni Kuboto. Just a
few years after Columbus is landing,
Giovanni now living in England
would change his name to John Cabot.
Henry would then decide to sponsor
his voyage and in 1497 cabinets depart
westward. Eventually he would land
and what he assumed was likely China,
but was in fact probably either
Newfoundland or Nova Scotia.
Kevin did not stay long on his voyage
and though he found evidence of human
activity in the area did not make
contact with any of the native Americans.
After his voyages. Records of
Cabot's existence become less clear,
though it's likely that he died
shortly after and unfitting end.
For someone who had now set the stage
for English involvement in North America
over the next century.
Multiple nations would attempt colonies
in the modern day United States,
most of which would fail.
The Americas were land of
great opportunity to the
Europeans for the cost of
that opportunity was contending with
disease, starvation, harsh weather,
isolation from the Homeworld and hostile
native Americans who had inhabited
lands from Millennia as France began its
colonization and exploration of America,
which would later lead to the places
not on as Quebec Acadia and Louisiana.
England would make its first
effort at a colony and modern day.
North Carolina on an island
known as Roanoke island
named after the local native
peoples.
On March 25th,
1584 Queen Elizabeth the first gave Sir
Walter really the right to organize a
colony in North America,
which would serve to establish
England's presence on the continent,
generate commerce, and to construct a
military base against their main enemies.
The Spanish one would be
established on Roanoke.
The colonist here will be the first
Englishman to cultivate and bring back to
England. Things like corn,
potatoes, and tobacco.
The first English child born in America,
Virginia dare was born in this. Connie,
on August 18th the granddaughter
and the colonies leader, John White,
118 people lived in this colony.
John White Left, returned to England,
but when he came back to the colony after
having been delayed for a few years,
there was no trace of them. The colonists
and most of the colony had vanished.
White found no evidence of a struggle
or a battle and much the settlement had
been dismantled and what looks
like a calmly and organized manner.
All that why could find was the
word Krakatoan carved on a tree.
White was unable to search nearby islands
because of weather. And to this day,
no one knows exactly what happened.
The first English colonization of
the new world was not only a failure,
it was a mystery.
The English had failed and their
first attempt and other attempts,
but would naturally try again.
17 years later on May 14th,
1607 the colony of Jamestown
was founded in Atlanta,
come to call Virginia after the
Virgin Queen Elizabeth, the settlers,
a mix of laborers and
gentlemen from England.
Expect the primary function of this call
need to be the extraction of gold and
silver.
However,
as was often a case for Europeans
coming to the new world with this death,
his time with his intention, they quickly
discovered that there was little here.
Within weeks of landing,
the men started being attacked by the
native pow hot and tribe the English.
However,
we're prepared to respond to this threat.
They came well armed and
constructive professional
fortifications within 20 days.
Perhaps they had secured
themselves militarily,
but the settlers soon began to realize
that they would not be without other
hardships.
The settlers unfortunately arrived at
Jamestown during one of the greatest
droughts within a thousand year record.
Furthermore,
not only had they arrive too late in
the season to effectively grow food,
but many of the columnists were
not skilled farmers are foreigners.
Many were expecting of trade for food
with the local natives for the drought was
affecting them as well.
The settler is found themselves too busy
trying to survive the harvest nearby
resources or look for golden silver.
On top of this disease was rampant and
perhaps we kill more in Jamestown and
starvation or the continuous
native American attacks.
The majority of colonists who lived
here with die of these hardships.
Within the first five or so years,
that population would go
from 500 to 60 John Smith,
the colonies leader was the man
holding this call need together.
It was he who insisted a new shipment
of supplies we sent from England and he
then install the very simple and straight
forward rule for the colonists quoting
the Bible. He said he who
will not work, will not eat,
directed mostly towards to settlements
upperclass and it was John Smith
primarily who held the most successful
negotiations with the native Americans.
He also named the region of New England,
a name which lasts to this day.
John Smith's contribution
to Jamestown was invaluable,
but he was returned to England after
being injured in an accidental gunpowder
explosion in 1609 the colonists entered
into what is known as the starving time
and are forced to eat
rats, horses, dogs, snakes,
and eventually whatever they could find.
In some instances they
would turn to cannibalism.
The natives kept attacking disease was
unchecked and paranoia was rampant.
Suspicions of Catholic or Spanish
plots ran high and indeed there is no
scientific evidence of arsenic
poisoning taking place here.
The colony was nearly abandoned until
the arrival of Thomas West third bear and
dilawar better known as Lord Delaware.
Delaware was the most effective leaders
since John Smith and helped her in the
colony around. Furthermore,
along with Lord Delaware,
a man by the name of John Ralf carried
with him something which would also help
shape the future fortunes of Jamestown,
a new strain of tobacco.
He intended to start growing.
The tobacco was very popular in England
and it would not only make Ralf a
wealthy man,
but save Jamestown Roth having become
an important figure in the Connie.
What Mary? The chief's
daughter, Pocahontas,
which would secure piece between
the [inaudible] and the English.
For a few years long enough
to get James Town on his feet.
The colony would now begin
to grow into the thousands,
many who came over for the next few
decades where what are known as indentured
servants.
These laborers sign contracts promising
to work in the area in exchange for
residents and voyage there.
After a specific amount of time
when they had paid off their debts,
they were free to go off on their own.
James also eventually saw the first
African slaves and American 16 1920 slaves
intended for the Spanish colonies
were brought to Jamestown,
though some were eventually
granted a degree of freedom.
Many other important historical events
would take place at Jamestown as well.
The first body of elected representatives
known as the house of burgesses would
assemble.
It was intended to represent the voices
of the inhabitants of Jamestown to make
it more agreeable. Though only
English men were allowed to vote.
The Polish Slovakian and German sellers,
we're not outraged.
They formed the first protest and refuse
to work until they were granted a right
to vote as well. Within
a month, it had worked.
Conflict with the native Americans would
eventually resume and would last for
decades within time.
However,
the English would weaken and eventually
destroy the power. Hot and confederacy.
Meanwhile to the north England was
expanding its presence in the new world.
Further and 1620 a group of pure attend
religious separatists from the Anglican
church known as the pilgrims would travel
to America originally relocating to
the Netherlands after having
been unwelcome and England,
feeling that the Anglican church
resembled a Catholic church far too much,
they decided instead to found
a settlement in a new world.
The settlements they let her felt could
grow to become a city on a hill serving
as an example of morality
and piety to Europe,
the pilgrims led by William Bradford
boarded a ship known as the May flower
along with a number of other English
merchants and craftsmen and set sail for
the new world. Eventually finding
a settlement and a Cape Cod area.
In Modern Day Massachusetts.
Before landing,
the colonist drew up what they
would call the Mayflower compact.
This established a set of laws which
the colony would follow and sell
disagreements between the Puritan and
non puritan settlers and the first winter
about half of the original settlers of
a dye. Toward the end of the winter,
formal relations with the
local native Americans began.
There was some disagreement among
the two sides at first. However,
the relationship between the English and
the native Americans here with turnout
to go very well.
At first,
the Wampanoag people would
even help the English survive,
teaching them new farming techniques
and familiarizing them with the land.
After a year of hard
work in general success,
the natives and pilgrims celebrated
the autumnal harvest together,
while not necessarily
celebrating the success of
everything going on. In general,
this feast would later become
the Thanksgiving holiday
and the 1630 is more of
the foundations for what would become
England's 13 colonies began to take root.
This growth would not be unimpeded.
However,
along with the native Americans who
were beginning to react to increased
pressure on them in a lens.
England was also competing in the theater.
It was Spain,
the Dutch,
Sweden for a little while and France and
July of 1636 the first major war in the
region with breakout,
the p Quad war.
It arose as a mixture of English expansion
into the region and the attempts of
the p tribe to dominate
trade in the region.
The war would primarily consists of the
two sides conducting raids against each
other and having skirmishes with the
wars, climax being what is
referred to as the mystic massacre,
wherein the English and their
native allies assaulted a
p Quad village burned it
and killed it,
likely over 500 people.
By the 1640s tens of thousands of English
settlers were living in the colonies
and the 16 fifty's a series of conflicts
would be game with a Dutch sparked by
conflict in Europe.
During the Anglo Dutch wars,
the English would conquer Dutch
territory in North America,
including most notably
the city of new Amsterdam,
which the English would
rename to New York.
In 1670 Charles 10 was founded paving
the way for the Carolina colonies.
Carolina being Latin for Charles,
named after Charles.
The second though the colonies were,
as I said in an in this time numbering
and the tens of thousands of people,
there was still a great demand for labor,
increasing the number of indentured
servants and African slaves into the
colonies.
In 1675 a major conflicts between the
English and the native American tribes
known as King.
Phillip's war would break out from
the strains of English expansion.
King Phillip refers
somewhat humorous leads.
The leader of the Wampanoag
tribe made a comment.
Thousands died in this war and significant
parts of New England where pillaged
and burned by the natives,
but the English would of course,
eventually when this war in 1678 with
the death of medic comment following this
war, England has secured his
position on the coastal regions.
Also in 1678 another major incident
occurred in colonial history,
Bacon's rebellion.
As land became scarcer,
the English and Virginia felt need
to push westward into native American
territory. Virginia Governor
William Berkeley. However,
it was trying to avoid conflict with the
native Americans for multiple reasons.
War was very strenuous and
trade was often very profitable.
With Len becoming scarcer,
indentured servants receive less than
ideal land surrounded by hostile natives
and felt powerless to
respond and response.
A group of both white and black men led
by Nathaniel Bacon began writing native
American villages, which occupied
land that they wanted to expand into.
On September 16th much of Jamestown
will be burned by the rebels,
had Nathaniel bacon not died of dysentery.
A month later,
the rebellion may have continued further.
Bacon's rebellion failed and the colonial
government was forced to respond and
indentured servitude having become more
costly and unstable to the wealthy elite,
the funded it was gradually stopped.
As a result,
the labor shortage and the sprawling
agricultural society that the south would
lead to a grid of the man for African
slaves and 1680 the French claim to
territory surrounding the Mississippi.
They called a great stretch
of land at Louisiana.
After Louie the 14th as England's
colonies continued to expand,
Francis did as well.
The European borders of the new world
began to touch both England and France and
claim land to Canada and had specific
interest it controlling the waterways of
North America such as the
Great Lakes and the Ohio River.
On March 4th, 1681 William Penn
was granted or well charted.
It found land known as Pennsylvania,
Latin for pens, forest.
This territory would increase Anglo
French tensions in the region.
This tension would lead to conflict
between the two nations. In fact,
four major wars often involving native
Americans in coinciding with conflict in
Europe and 1688 King William's war,
the first war was fought,
though the borders would remain
essentially similar. Five years later,
Queen Anne's war would break out
between England or as it was now,
Britain against France and Spain.
The war would last for 11 years in
cell 1713 with Breton as a clear victor
getting more territory and 1740
king George's war broke out.
This war saw slight
French military victory.
Though little territorial changes
were really made. The colonies,
particularly New England, however,
would suffer great losses.
The lack of resolution is toward any of
the major problems here with lead to the
final fourth major showed between the
colonies of Britain and France in North
America in 1754 referred to in the United
States as the French and Indian war.
The war would settle the dispute
between Britain and France and lay the
foundations for the future of the
continent, Britain and France,
where arguably evenly matched,
but for different reasons.
The population of the British
colonies had grown to about 2 million,
but from Louisiana to Canada, there
were only about 60,000 French Canadians.
The French, however, still had a very
strong emphasis on military in the region.
Furthermore,
the French had done better at maintaining
peaceful relations with the native
Americans and the British and accordingly,
most native tribes involved
with Psi with the French,
with the exception of
tribes such as the Iroquois.
The war would break out over territorial
disputes around basically the Great
Lakes and the Ohio River with particular
emphasis on the Ohio country here.
When a 21 year old British officer from
Virginia named at George Washington
engage a company of French forces in a
small skirmish called the battle of his
Human Ville, Glenn War
broke out. During this war,
the colonies would meet
as one for the first time.
It's something known as the
Albany Congress wherein a
48 year old polymath named
Benjamin Franklin would suggest
a common defense of the colonies.
For the first four years of the war.
The French were consistently winning
against the British and 1758 however,
the tide of war changed
when General John Forbes,
the Forbes expedition with the intended
goal of winning three specific victories
established by the British
Secretary of State, William Pitt,
after whom the city of Pittsburgh,
his name's he would succeed at to drive
in the French from Fort Duquesne in the
Ohio Valley and Louie
Berg and Nova Scotia.
The third invasion would
fail with a backup car,
y'all in which around 3000 French troops
defeated 18,000 British throughout the
rest of the war.
However,
the British would begin to consistently
win over the French in 1760 when general
James Wolff would die during
his victorious assault
salt on the French at the
battle of the plains of Abraham,
the British would occupy Quebec City,
which essentially allowed them
to capitulate the rest of Canada.
Though the war would continue for three
more years into 1763 the main portion of
it had ended with the battle
of the plains of Abraham.
The war ended with the treaty of Paris
officially that year and in that the
French chose to retain their
more profitable Caribbean
colonies over disputing
their holdings in North America.
Britain would claim the rest of Canada
and the Ohio region and Francis Louisiana
territory would be given to Spain as
compensation for the loss of Florida.
Britain was now essentially the
unchallenged power in North America.
Though this position came at a cost,
the British had nearly doubled their
national debt and had to increase taxes
across the empire,
including the North American colonies,
which would literally the complications
in relations with the colonies following
the French and Indian war, Pontiac's
rebellion would take place. A reaction.
Depression now felt by the
natives from British expansion.
Thousands of British soldiers and colonist
would be killed or displaced by the
natives would eventually be defeated.
The policy regarding their subjugation
was lightened following the rebellion.
Soon thereafter,
the royal proclamation of 1763 four
bay colonists from settling west of the
Appalachian Mountains.
The fact that colonists were not only
forbidden from settling west of the
Appalachians,
but were in fact sometimes removed by
the British military forcibly would
agitate the colonists.
Further,
the royal proclamation of 1763 would
be among the first of several incidents
over the coming decade that would lead
to strain between the British and the 13
colonies colonies,
which Heather had enjoyed a high
degree of independence tensions,
but grow throughout the 1760s
as the British did things
such as imposed a number
of taxes on the call has to satisfy
these war debts like the sugar act,
the Currency Act, and the stamp
act. They also kept the army.
They're following the war,
which the colonists felt was unnecessary
as not only did they massively
outnumber the frontier native Americans,
but indeed most male colonist owned guns
and we're expected to be in militias.
The quartering act was passed,
which required American colonists to
provide housing for these soldiers.
British soldiers could also enter
colonial homes to ensure that they were
following through with these regulations.
The colonists protested these things to
a degree at which officials from nine
colonies met incentive British government,
the declaration of rights in grievances,
and I do mean to emphasize
the British government here.
It's not just King George. The third
making the rules, it's parliament as well.
The colonist. We're not angered
about the taxes themselves,
especially considering how much lower
they were in the colonies and they were in
England. They were more angered by the
fact that they had no say in these taxes.
They had no representatives in
parliament or as it's often called,
they were mad about taxation
without representation.
Parliament actually does end
up repeating the stamp act,
but it's a little relief to the colonies
because they've passed the declaratory
act and the town's index.
Soon thereafter stating that the British
parliament had the same right to rule
over the colonies as a did England in
placing indirect taxes on things like
paper, t and glass and the 17 seven
these protests became more intense
thing, such as the Boston massacre
occurred, which wasn't really a massacre.
It was an exaggeration of an incident
in which British soldiers shot into a
violent crowd that was
deemed self-defense.
Three years later in 1773 the Boston
tea party occurred and incident in which
the sons of liberty disguise themselves
as native Americans and toss entire
shipment of t overboard in defiance
of the British. After this,
the British began to crack down even
harder and the colonies began to respond
with even more defiance and in 1774
at least is something called the first
continental congress.
Attending this first congress were men
such as Patrick Henry, Samuel Adams,
and John Adams.
Now,
this Congress did not assemble a
start talking about independence.
Very few people in fact even
talked about independence.
In cell 1776 it assembled to decide
what to do about an emerging conflict.
Their initial goal was to try to
reason with a British garment,
but that essentially failed.
This would lead to the second continental
congress in which other figures like
Thomas Jefferson and George Washington,
and to the stage,
the plan was still not initially to
separate from the British empire,
but the tries to demand further that
the conditions being met by the British
government possibly even to organize a
colonies into revolt in a spring of 1775
however,
when British soldiers attempted to
seize weaponry from American patriots,
the men resisted leading to the
battles of Lexington and Concord.
The first shot was fired at these battles.
Often remember it as the
shot heard round the world,
the British would win the battles,
but it would mark the
beginning of an entire war.
British forces began clashing
with American malicious.
On June 15th the Continental Congress
officially adopted the Continental Army
and put George Washington in charge of it.
On July 5th the colonist addressed the
olive branch petition to King George,
the third and an effort to
avoid further escalation of war.
But in August when the proclamation for
suppressing rebellion and sedition was
issued following the
battle of Bunker Hill,
stating that the colonies were in
rebellion and would be subdued by forests,
hopes of achieving peace where greatly
diminished war would continue and the
congress,
and in fact the whole nation gradually
just began splitting from the British
empire more and more until on July 4th,
1776 the continental congress declared
to the United States was an independent
nation.
It was now all or nothing.
The British began sending large amounts
of their own soldiers as well as hiring
mercenaries from Hessia.
British forces would capture New York
from rebel forces and would cause
Washington to retreat with
the British closing in.
They felt that they could win the war
within a year and American morale began to
drop.
However,
on Christmas Day 1776 forces on the
general Washington surprise attack that
British and Hash and forces at the battle
of Trenton and one which encouraged
the rebels to keep going
the following year,
the British would attempt to close in
from the north in what's referred to as a
Saratoga campaign. Though they were
upheld. It was costly in American spirit,
drops his Wyatt and make camp
for the winter and valley forge.
The winter here was very hard on American
troops, but an exiled Prussian officer.
The Baron von Steuben
would be instrumental and
shredding American troops and
pressure military tactics.
Up to this point,
much of the success of the American
army was in guerrilla warfare,
but on the open field,
Washington was forced to contend with
the fact that he was essentially sending
militias up against
it, better trained and better equipped
to professional army. Interestingly,
for unknown reasons,
the British chose not to
attack the American army at
Valley forge had they done
so. It's very possible that the war
could have ended following this winter.
The rebel side received some aid.
France now having confidence
in the rebels abilities,
openly allies itself
with the United States,
Spain and the Netherlands
would also join the war,
distracting Britain on other fronts.
Now,
allied nations being a part of the
American revolution are often only glanced
over or sometimes even,
I hate to say intentionally left out,
but the reality is that without foreign
help, especially from the French,
the American revolution probably would
have failed the American side needed to
funding the supplies and the troops,
especially on a sees as the British at
this time had the most powerful navy on
earth. And as we shall see in some
instances like the battle of Yorktown,
which we'll get to in a second,
there are even more French
soldiers and there are Americans.
The war continued in 1780 the
British found success at Charleston,
but where to feed it in the north
following the battle of Springfield on
September 28th,
1781 the siege of Yorktown begin
the seed with us for a month,
but on October 19th that combined American
and French armies had defeated the
British.
Though the war would continue officially
for two more years until a 1783 this
was the last major battle
with the piece of Paris.
The British would recognize American
sovereignty and seed it to the territory
east of the Mississippi.
The United States was now
a fully independent nation
with the British ceiling
home. The American Victor's now found
themselves freed of the old government,
but now faced with a new
challenge building a new one.
It's incorrect to think that the concept
of the United States we have to date
was already in everyone's mind.
The government had to walk on eggshells
essentially to avoid further separation
and rebellion.
There was a very real threat of
something like Virginia or Massachusetts
operating as a separate nation
and splitting from the union.
The period of 1783 to 1789 is often
called the confederation period named so
because the United States
was still operating off the
articles of confederation.
The articles can federation
left the central government,
which only consisted of a congress week
and without much power to levy taxes,
organized trade, enforce laws,
raise an army, et cetera.
Most of the governing was
left to the individual states.
Essentially we had the states,
but they weren't fully the United States.
Many of the founding fathers felt that
the only way that the United States can
be held together as a large nation was
if they adopted a new constitution with a
stronger central government with
Shay's rebellion against the corrupt
Massachusetts government and
ineffective American government.
The desire grew stronger.
Delegates would reconvene in Philadelphia
in 1787 with the intent of reshaping
the articles of confederation,
but would find themselves instead
writing a new constitution.
The constitution of the United States
after long debate will be past a document
basically lays the foundation
for the United States. Up Today.
It organizes the government
into three branches,
the legislative and judicial branches.
Each branch was designed to check each
other to ensure democracy and as his
constitution remains one of the shortest
and the world attempted to ensure
limited governmental power,
the voting population would elect
to figures to represent them and the
government and it would not really always
directly vote on issues themselves.
The first president of the United
States was George Washington,
who was unanimously elected along
with its vice president John Adams.
In 1781 the first 10 amendments were
added to the constitution to limit the
power of the government
further and established a
number of rights and freedoms
for the populace and ease concerns
about a central government that was so
powerful. The first protect the
rights of Americans to speech,
religion and organization and protest
the second their right to bear arms to
guard against governmental corruption.
The third preventing the quartering of
soldiers and American homes, et Cetera.
This constitution was not about the
government granting people rights.
It's about the people renting
the government to write
their will with a large
number of restrictions
on what it could do.
The United States was not the
first democracy in the world.
It was not even the only
democracy at the time.
The British even who are
sometimes portrayed as
tyrannical absolute monarchist
were relative to the rest of Europe.
A fairly democratic nation.
Much of the American revolution was
about not having the same rights,
not that these rights were
entirely in existence.
There are a number of reasons that the
British didn't just grant the American
colonists equal
representation in parliament,
but they mainly boiled down to the
fact that not even most of Britain was
equally represented in parliament.
Giving Americans equal representation
would have caused a bigger situation than
it sounds like. Keep in mind, for
the more at the start of the country,
only about 6% of the
population could vote.
This was the population
of white landowning males.
It was not unheard of prior to this for
the wives of landowning males and for
free black men to vote in some situations,
but these reits were eventually
revoked as time went on,
which will be important to understand.
As centuries progress and
the 1790 [inaudible] we see
the United States began to
take a more familiar shape.
The population was about 4 million
people just over one 100th of what it is
today. You had to, this
population was on the move.
A major concern was the
acquired land to the West.
The northwest ordinance of 1787 did more
than just establish the first territory
of the United States.
It laid the foundation for how westward
expansion and the eventual admission of
new states could take place.
These new territories would eventually
be divided into new states of Ohio,
Michigan, Illinois,
Indiana, and Wisconsin.
We also see the rise of political parties
in the United States. During this time.
The federalists and the Democratic
Republicans with the first a prominent
figurehead of the federalist
was Alexander Hamilton,
the secretary of the Treasury,
who was instrumental in creating the
national bank and structuring American
trade.
Thomas Jefferson typically aligned with
the Democratic Republicans who favored a
comparatively more domestically
focused and democratic United States.
When the French Revolution broke
out and became more intense,
the two political parties found
themselves taking unofficial sides.
The federalist who found Brent to be
their most valuable trading partner
supported British efforts against France.
A Democratic Republicans were sympathetic
towards similar goals of the French
revolutionaries against their king
and for democracy supported their
revolutionary aims. President Washington
was very much bothered by all of this.
He was very much against the concepts of
both political parties at home and the
lions has abroad. The French called upon
the Americans to honor their alliance,
but Washington maintains neutrality when
the Jay Treaty was signed in 1795 which
established Britain as America's
closest trading partner.
The US had mildly chosen this side,
though this treaty was very unpopular
and the US, as we shall see,
isn't that remain on the side mainly
because of British continue to do things
like arming hostile native Americans and
capturing American sailors unfortunate
in to serve and the British navy.
It was commonly felt by the government
that the Jay Treaty can be forged and the
one sign in the past with the French
was void because it was signed with the
King of France, not the
French republic. Therefore,
the United States was not obligated
to assist a French militarily.
In 1797 George Washington retired from
his office and the precedent for the
presidents to serve only two terms.
This would later become law.
John Adams would succeed him in the
following election with Thomas Jefferson
serving as vice president Adams,
a federalist took stronger federalist
positions and George Washington,
but still wanted the United States
to remain for the most part. Neutral.
This soon kind of falls apart as failed
negotiations lead to the quasi war with
France and unofficial naval
conflict between the two.
Adams would also pass the
alien and sedition acts,
which made it more difficult
for immigrants to come
into the country and allow
the government to imprison and deport
anyone who is deemed dangerous.
Though this included even people
who criticize Adam's presidency,
the acts were quickly repealed,
but it just goes to show that some
concepts like free speech weren't firmly
indisputably entrenched in American
politics. The concept of America,
yet the quasi war would end when
Napoleon who was more reasonable than the
French revolutionary government came
to power and negotiate peace with the
American diplomats.
There was popular support for war,
but both the US and the points,
French empire had many
other things to worry about.
In 1801 Thomas Jefferson
was elected president and he
begins to start changing a
few things around. Jefferson did
not like the federal government.
You're not like banks.
He was a farmer from Virginia and he
was much more sympathetic to the aims of
the majority of the American population
were farmers and the federalists were
during his presidency.
The northwest of the nation began to take
shape when Ohio becomes a 17 state in
1803 much more significantly.
Napoleon had recently required
the Louisiana from Spain. However,
when the French lost Haiti,
Napoleon essentially felt that the rest
of America was useless territory and he
sold at the Jefferson
for a very cheap price.
Essentially purchasing what would become
several future states from France for
what would today be $300 million or
about $23 million estate state. Again,
by today's standards,
President Jefferson later sends out an
expedition led by men named Merryweather
Lewis and William Clark to explore the
American West and establish relations
with major native American tribes.
They would succeed in doing much of this
with the help up has shown a woman's
secretary [inaudible] though they did
not of course find the northwest passage,
which there were also asked to look
for this and Jefferson speculation that
mastodons could still
live in the American west.
Just goes to show how little Americans
knew of what was in the West.
When James Madison became president in
1809 many of the problems and of strains
with Britain still existed.
The British was still capturing American
sailors harassing American ships and
arming native Americans
in northwest territory.
Namely a confederation led with
Shawnee chief to comes up in 1812 and
retaliation to these offenses. The United
States with declare war on Britain.
The British were far too occupied
by the Napoleonic wars too.
At first launch response, though they were
able to, along with our native allies,
hold off American expansion into Canada.
The British would also attempt to blockade
American trade and free and recruit
many American slaves into their armies.
The American army at this time was
not an efficient fighting force.
The concept of a large standing
army was considered dangerous.
Too many Americans at the time,
including Congress. Instead,
much of the American military relied
lied on militias that would be called up
whenever war was a threat.
When Napoleon was defeated in April of
1814 the British were able to focus more
on the war with America.
American forces were overwhelmed.
They were defeated at the battle of
Bladensburg and the British thing captured
Washington DC burning down the White
House and attempting to burn down much of
the city though a heavy
storm put out these fires.
A month later during
the battle of Baltimore,
Francis Scott Key would write his
famous poem, the Star spangled banner,
which would later become America's
national anthem in December of 1814 it was
beginning to look as though
the war would end in a draw.
The two sides met in Ghent, Belgium
to form a peace treaty. Accordingly,
fighting would continue even after the
peace treaty was signed as word of it had
not yet reached America,
such as the infamous battle of New
Orleans where Andrew Jackson defeated a
fourth in British over three
times as large as the zone.
The war was indeed a truce.
Though the United States arguably suffered
more in the British following the war
of 1812 a sense of national pride swept
through the United States road and can
now building to facilitate
trade throughout the nation
and expansion into other
parts of it picked up with particular
emphasis on things like the ability of the
newly invented steamboat soon and the
later 1820s at the introduction of the
railroad will begin to
reshape transportation across
a very large areas of the
United States. Factories would
spring up across the country,
primarily in the north with the south
still focusing more so on agriculture.
Though this advancement in technology
and production did absolutely make this
south of Richard and
more productive as well.
These factories were worth by women and
the hundreds of thousands of immigrants
pouring into the nation, redefining
the American workday and work for
us.
All of these innovations as well as others
are part of what is called the market
revolution,
which was a result of the industrial
revolution and when pave the way for
America to grow into a much larger power.
As time went on,
hundreds of thousands of settlers were
pouring into the western lands over the
decades,
which would eventually lead to the
concept of manifest destiny that God had
given the America the right to
spread out across a continent.
In 1823 we see something called the
Monroe doctrine named after President John
Monroe, essentially stating
that the United States would
not only prohibit future
European colonization and
lands that they had claimed,
but in fact the whole hemisphere will
be safe guarded by the United States.
The U s was not actually militarily
powerful enough to defend the entire
Americas from multiple European powers.
However,
the British join with
them on this doctrine.
This would mark the beginning of America
coming out of isolation and perhaps
sowed the seeds for the later beginning
of American imperialism powered by,
as we discussed,
the industrial revolution,
which was having grit effects
this new open country.
In 1828 Andrew Jackson
was elected president.
Having had an essentially lifelong
military history and having come from a
poorer family, he was seen as relatable
to the common man. Accordingly,
much of what he did was on
behalf of the common person,
such as opposed in a national banks,
which you felt benefited.
The upperclass is primarily and extending
voting rights to May landless whites.
Jackson,
who had been a southerner very active
in conflict with the native Americans,
also signed the Indian removal act, which
intended to move the Cherokee Choctaw,
Muskogee,
Chickasaw,
and Seminole peoples and the
southern states to new territory.
Many Americans protested the Indian
removal act as inhumane as it had been,
an intention for many dating back as
early as it founding fathers, in fact,
to attempt to integrate native
Americans in twice society,
but the government went forward with
it leading to what is remembered as the
trail of tears,
the path these natives falled on a forest
relocation to modern day Oklahoma on
which a quarter of them or about
10,000 innocent people would perish.
The Seminole tribe in Florida
specifically, however,
would resist and would lead to the second
seminar war and eventually the third,
the 1830s we're a very busy time in
America for other reasons as well,
along with political and
industrial movements.
Social movements like the
second great awakening,
a Protestant bliss movement swept through
the nation as well as a large number
of moments calling for the abolition of
slavery and the roots of the feminist
movement. Public schools would pop up
in the north. However, in the south,
people were skeptical of
government education or it's
with the native Americans
continued in 1835 Texas Rosa from
Mexico directed by American settlers and
declared itself an independent nation.
Only a decade later,
the United States would
admit Texas into union.
The United States didn't laid
their eyes on California,
but the Mexican empire still claims both
Texas and California and the American
invasion is the region would
lead to the Mexican American war.
The war ended within two years when
American forces captured Mexico City and
incorporated territory, which now makes
up much of the southwest. Soon thereafter,
the California gold rush would
commence by securing this territory.
American territory now stretched from the
Atlantic to the Pacific in between the
border is agreed to with
Mexico and British Canada.
The goal is a manifest destiny. It
seemed were coming to fruition. However,
an issue concerning these territories
was whether or not slavery will be legal
in them,
and this was a matter of fierce debate.
Originally align placed here divided
territories that were to be established as
slave holding a free states.
Typically as one state on one side of
the line was admitted to the union,
people on the other side would scramble
to make a territory you state to keep it
balanced within congress.
At a time when new states were
frequently being admitted into the union,
it was suggested that these new states
decide for themselves whether or not they
will be slave holding.
This leads to conflict,
even actual fighting
within these new states,
Kansas specifically in the 1850s
this conflict came at a time when,
as I said,
tension over slavery was growing.
Books like uncle Tom's cabin began
bringing life of slavery to light and John
Brown slave rebellion, which
failed, sparked fears over
further slave uprisings.
In 1804 the Haitians had rebelled
against their slave masters and tortured,
killed and expelled all
whites from the island,
even friendly ones solidifying southern
opinion of abolition and the dangers
they felt that posed.
Yet in a north,
it was commonly felt that a nation which
held slaves could not be considered a
truly free nation. One such northerner
was a man named Abraham Lincoln.
His election to the presidency in 1860
was only 40% of the popular vote leads
the final fight over slavery, the
civil war. Now before we begin here,
there is a lot of the bait as to whether
or not the civil war was fought over
slavery or state's rights and people to
this day are still quite attached to the
issue.
We can see definitely several examples
of strain between the north and south
overstates rise throughout history,
which were not was slavery.
The south was and is indeed different
from the north and a number of ways and
indeed the common person on both sides
was not really concerned about slavery,
but one of the civil war
was quite complicated.
The bottom line is without slavery,
the civil war may very well
not have ever happened.
Out of the interest of
preserving the union,
Lincoln stated he would not touch
slavery in a places in what had already
existed. Though his intention, the halt,
its expansion into new
territories of the nation.
We're the final straw for the south or
presenting a threat to slavery as a whole.
Before Lincoln even took office, South
Carolina, Florida, Mississippi, Georgia,
Alabama,
Louisiana,
and Texas seceded from the Union and
form the confederate states of America,
Georgia and South Carolina had hinted
over the possibility of succeeding from
the union since the revolution
now the union was falling apart.
Conflict did not begin immediately,
but when the south on a president,
Jefferson Davis began demanding
federal property in a territory,
though offering to pay for it. The North
refused. Accordingly, the south attack,
the north held fort Sumpter in South
Carolina. On April 12th, 1860 war,
Virginia,
Arkansas,
North Carolina and Tennessee would
subsequently joined the south as well.
The civil war had begun.
Both sides expected a very short war,
though they each expected
to win the war very quickly.
The North was much more industrial,
much more populated,
had twice the railroads and was better
prepared for war in the south was the
south harbor. Merely had
the fight, a defensive war,
and we're out northern efforts
to recline a territory.
They furthermore felt that
their agricultural wealth
would cause foreign nations
like Britain and France to support them.
Of course, the support that not come.
The first major battle of the war
was the first battle of bull run,
also known as the battle of Manassas,
the confederate victory.
Here we'll begin to foreshadow that the
war will be longer than anticipated.
The union's strategy began with a failed
attempt to capture the confederate
capital of Richmond,
Virginia,
and later evolve the cutoff
to south from outside trade,
which meant blockading made your tray
ports it controlling the Mississippi.
The war would soon be divided
into Western and eastern fronts.
In 1862 former US general Robert E.
Lee with affects the confederate side
with a number of confederate successes,
especially in the east.
The prospect of a confederate victory
was becoming more and more realistic for
the first few years of the war in
1863 however, things began to change,
though having enjoyed a decent amount
of victory leaves aggressive strategies
would backfire at the battle
of Gettysburg. In July of
1863, uh, union victory,
which is Optima guarded as
a turning point of the war.
The following day on July 4th,
Ulysses s grant captured Vicksburg
subsequently allowing the Union to control
the Mississippi and splitting
the confederacy into grant
was soon made general
of all the union forces.
Confederate goal is to win the war by and
been in north were lost and now how to
fight defensively.
Earlier that year,
Lincoln had issued the emancipation
proclamation and executive order,
which intended to free African slaves,
still enslaved in rebel.
Territory's though not those in union
territory with the confederates on the
defensive to the union's strategy now
was to exhaust confederate supplies and
pin them to hasten the end of the war.
A prime example of this was William
Tecumseh Sherman's march to the sea,
which destroyed one fifth
of all farms in Georgia.
The confederates held out for as
long as possible, but on April 9th,
1865 general Robert E.
Lee surrender to general grant at the
Aba Maddix courthouse in Virginia,
the rest of the confederacy would soon
follow the civil war with railroads.
Telegraphs are in cloud warships and other
technologies is considered one of the
first industrial wars.
Foreshadowing the destructiveness that
come in future wars following the war,
the south was left impoverished
by prolonged conflict.
It was not fully able to
sustain the civil war.
It remains the deadliest war ever fought
by Americans and American history with
around 700,000 deaths, a heavy
price to pay, but following the war,
many things changed.
The 13th 14th and 15th amendments passed,
which abolished slavery sell the issues
of African American citizenship and
extended the right to vote to blacks.
But this was very much contested,
especially in the south. As
we will see this. Furthermore,
secure the power of the federal government
over the states and led to a stronger
sense of unity in the country.
Prior to this,
people are more associated with their
individual state, the nation as a whole.
People even refer to the
United States as a plural eg.
The United States are moving their army,
not moving.
It's army that changed
following the civil war.
President Lincoln would not live
to see these changes, however,
or the official end of the war as he was
assassinated in Ford's theatre on April
14th,
1865 he was of course in favor of these
things and though while he is sometimes
seen as the great a massive pater,
he and many in the north felt that
slavery was wrong but did not exactly see
blacks as equals. Many Americans were
not opposed returning the former slaves,
the nation of origin,
rather than deal with what they felt
would be trouble from integrating blacks
into white society.
Specifically the country of Liberia,
America's only colony in
Africa established in 1820s
as a home for freed African
slaves. But for now at this time,
independent nation. However,
the most would of course
remain in the United States.
In the next video we will
discuss how this all unfolds,
what happens from here and how the United
States is able to reassemble itself
following it's split to support the
production of videos like these,
a link to the channels patriot and
can be found in the description below.
For more videos like this and
videos on many other subjects.
Be sure to check out fire of learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.